whether you enjoy zack snyder's batman
be superman or not the Justice League is
assembling and you may be surprised to
hear that the newest member is actually
the Green Goblin himself I'm Simon and
this is your jla news updates it was
confirmed this week that spider-man and
the boondock saints actor willem dafoe
has joined the cast of Zack Snyder's
upcoming Justice League movies The
Hollywood Reporter reports that Defoe
will play the part of a good guy in the
action films Dafoe is no stranger to
superhero movies as he played the evil
Marvel character Green Goblin in the
spider-man films from Sam Raimi his role
is unconfirmed at this point but we do
know he will fight alongside Ben Affleck
as Batman Henry Cavill as Superman gal
gadot as Wonder Woman Jason Momoa as
Aquaman Ezra Miller as the flash and ray
Fisher as sidewalk in the film The
Hollywood Reporter explains that Dafoe
will appear in both parts of the Justice
League film the first of which is due
out in November 2017 with the second
half arriving in 2019 production began
last week who could you see Dafoe as
Martian Manhunter Hawk man maybe even
elongated man let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter i'm
at the jagan or thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot